I'd like to ask everybody to sit on the
floor if you don't mind all right this
is my first time at the show
um this has been such an eye-opener for
me and you're just so welcoming and it's
like that makes people feel really good
and I just love you guys I am really
surprised overwhelmed I knew the movies
I knew coming into it this was going to
be great but there's just so much fun
and safety and respect and empowerment
to be had I was crying backstage before
I came out but I want to tell you why I
was crying there are so many different
things we as women are looking for how
did you know to speak to the
multi-facets of women and write that
into the show that starts at the top and
Channing Tatum is our director slash
like Father Figure and he created this
environment that everyone feels truly
welcome and seen and empowered it opens
with like what you kind of Imagine would
be like a stereotypical full like male
review to be there's a male in C and
he's kind of gross and and then there's
that twist that there's a female emcee
and that's what I think is so special is
that we get to go on this journey
together that's the message of the show
when they were doing the storytelling in
the beginning what was a thought that
came to your mind
I think that was very nice that I did
feel you know it was
being around all this
manly flash is a little bit
but I I did feel a very respected it
just brought us all out and who we are
and it was just very special it's a nice
thing everybody's done for us here may I
ask Helen what you know what's your
thoughts and feelings like I felt I was
among friends like I just felt they were
such gentlemen that um we were just
gonna have fun why is it so safe in here
that's the space that China wanted to
create yeah I think that was the vision
from the very beginning
and I think he nailed it what's the
words and phrases you say about kind of
the permission space and respect if you
decide while watching the show that you
don't want attention you can always say
unicorn which is our safe word and the
guys will listen and they will respect
that you say unicorn people write us
letters and say you know my husband of
30 years died and this is the first time
a man has like held my hand or slow
danced with me or like made this
connection with me and how special that
is it feels like this is a safe space to
be who you are
um no matter what that is you're asking
people
to take off the armor and if there's
anywhere that armor should be removed it
should be here
can I ask each of you gentlemen to
describe your experience doing this show
I would say fulfillment
just being
what I like seeing is how guarded some
of the women are and then when they
leave how open and how empowered they
are the show help me with my confidence
you know
when you think of a male stripper you
think six feet tall 200 pounds muscle
and this show made me realize that like
we're all so different and just like all
shapes and sizes of women are
appreciated
it helped me with my confidence to feel
like that's not always about looks
teaches me a lot about people and it's
cool to see what a male review can
actually be we get messages all the time
from patrons and fans saying you know
this changed my life or you know I've
had experiences in the past that you
know made me feel differently but now
after seeing your show I'm I'm ready I'm
open again I think you guys have really
got it right the way that you paint a
picture of a woman I'm looking for a
different tone than what necessarily a
lot of society is messaging especially
for a younger generation because I see
other things going in the wrong
direction for young girls about how men
are supposed to treat them it's just
kind of emotional like I had a daughter
during Colby and that was a special time
for me and it changed my look on women
in general
so to have women come here like you
and share your testimony about how it
makes how it makes you feel is like
rewarding for me this is so kind and
different this is getting it right I
have a lot of queer women and men that
contact me and they say are we allowed
to come to the show and I'm like of
course you can like there's nothing
holding you back and then after the show
they hit me up and they're like we felt
so empowered and welcomed the genuine
connection that you get here at the show
I think that's what I take away most
from it is you know we get all walks of
life in here and
um you have to come in here and it's a
space where no judgment is passed ladies
will you do me the favor of just sort of
echoing a sentiment about how today made
you feel well it made me feel really
good
very respectful I appreciate it that was
really a lot of fun
you know I am married and I felt very
safe you guys are profound you take care
of people this is a memory making day oh
just hold on to it so dearly thank you
everybody thank you thank you
foreign
[Music]